So we have no shortage of gas lighting in
2020 and specifically around the pandemic.
But what really takes the cake, in my view,
is that Fox News has now started to pretend
that they never downplayed the virus, that
they never said it was a hoax, that they never
said it was a great time to get on an airplane
or to go to a restaurant because there wouldn't
be anybody else there. They are pretending
they never gave platforms to any right wing
clowns that wanted to minimize the virus and
defend President Trump. And they are now trying
to revise history, much like Donald Trump
has tried to do. And they are doing it because
they're starting to get sued for having spread
Corona virus disinformation. Here's Sean HANNITY.
Remember, HANNITY famously put up an image
a few weeks ago bragging about corona virus
deaths. Zero. Here's HANNITY the same night
ridiculing everyone who took this seriously
from day one.
Tonight, I can report the sky is absolutely
falling. We are all doomed. The end is near.
The apocalypse is imminent. And you're going
to all die, all of you, in the next 48 hours.
And it's all President Trump's fault.
Here's HANNITY again, downplaying it on March
9th.
In all seriousness. I think we've got to be
very real with the American people. I don't
like how we are scaring people unnecessarily.
And that is that unless you have a compromise
on an immune system of this compromised and
you are older and you have other underlying
health issues, you are not going to die. Ninety
nine percent from this virus, correct?
That's correct. And it's good to be with you
again.
All right. So that's the point. I mean, what
this scaring the living hell out of people.
And I I see it again as like, oh, let's bludgeon
Trump with this new hoax that was Republican
bomb throwing Trump sycophant Congressman
Doug Collins very much agreeing with Sean
Hannity's assessment. But most importantly,
HANNITY actually calling it a hoax. Now, here's
HANNITY 11 days later saying he was always
taking it seriously.
Yeah. I think we kind of laugh at it, but
not to laugh at here. By the way, this program
has always taken the Corona virus seriously.
And we've never called the virus a hoax because
what they're doing, trying to bludgeon the
president out there, politicizing of this
virus, while predictable, despicable, repulsive,
all of the above.
Here are other segments from Fox News, including
Jeanine Pirro saying Corona virus is proof
merely of an anti Trump agenda. HANNITY calling
the virus a political weapon, the now fired
host, Trish Regan. We'll get to her later
saying the left is stoking chaos. Laura Ingram
saying the virus is a leftist smear campaign
and on and on and on. Here's lunatic Jesse
Waters downplaying it on March 3rd.
You want to know how I really feel about the
coronavirus, Juan? If I get it, I'll beat
it. I'm not lying. It's called the power of
positive thinking. And I think America needs
to wake up to that. I'm not afraid of the
Corona virus. And no one else should be that
afraid.
And then here is the same Jesse Waters, not
even a month later on April 1st, pretending
he was always taking it seriously. But there
were some Democrats who weren't taking it
seriously.
Cuomo was saying, go eat out in New York City.
De Blasio had all the schools open. Nancy
Pelosi said, bring your friends to Chinatown
and go to the bars. Joe Biden said the travel
ban was racist. Every column in The New York
Times, The Washington Post downplayed this
thing. And actually, Morning Joe had the audacity
the other day to say that everybody saw this
coming in January. Germany's segments. Morning
Joe did on the virus in January 1. They booked
a guy who said, don't worry about this virus,
worry about the flu. Finally, everyone's on
board. Young people, old people. Left, right.
We're all in this together now and we need
to stay together until we beat.
So now Jesse Waters saying he was one of the
few people taking it seriously all along.
They are now gaslighting. We could do examples
of this all day long and they're simply taking
the lead from Trump. This is what you have
to really understand about this entire sort
of echo chamber. For weeks, Trump downplayed
the virus and so did Fox News. So did Rush
Limbaugh. So did everybody.
Now, Trump is pretending he never downplayed
it, pretending he always took it seriously,
pretending he always knew it was going to
be a pandemic. Think he said last week he
knew it was a pandemic before it was even
being said publicly. And so now Fox News is
doing the exact same thing. They're very predictable
caricatures, in a sense, truly sad state of
affairs in the country. But all of this is
completely.
Predictable when it comes down to knowledge
and facts and thinking this was exactly what
we would have assumed that they were going
to do. And of course, the real concern, the
serious issue at the tail end of this, whenever
we get to it, is that they may get away with
it. They have a confident, dishonest ignorance
is the kind of best way I can summarize it.
They are dishonest. They are ignorant to the
facts, but they do so confidently on their
airwaves. And unfortunately, unless we have
a long memory, they may not suffer because
of it. And so my greatest fear is, of course,
that the death toll will be so much higher
than it needed to be because of the terrible,
terrible repp response from the president
and the terrible responses that we saw from
the right wing media that basically just play
to trump space. That's concern number one.
The death toll, once it's all said and done
and it's time to decide, are we reelecting
Trump? Or are we voting him out? I worry that
that confident, irresponsible, ignorant dishonesty
will lead to too many people saying would
have been worse without Trump. Let's vote
to reelect him. And that is genuinely an increasing
fear that I have because of the degree to
which that cultish following of Trump is convinced
that he's been doing the right thing all along.
We'll keep following it and trying to make
the case that that is not the situation.